yeah thanks for uh thanks for having me
come speak here at this event which is a
very very interesting and really glad to
be part of it so what I want to talk
about today is some work we're doing and
actually just to mention here some work
sort of my thing about this began in a
collaboration with dan hunt locker
Cornell and your I'll escovitch and ash
position at Stanford looking at some of
the issues i'll be telling about in a
second and then sort of from there it
continued on into some joint work which
will be in the latter parts talk with
segal or n actually continuing on to
some ongoing work that's the girl I've
been doing with a Berkeley undergrad
here Mini's Raghavan which i'll post a
bulletin last slide so the curve issue I
wanted to talk about here is that I mean
we've been seeing in the in the online
world is the scrolls and systems where
users have these very long lifetimes in
the system where we're in effect rather
than just think about a sort of snapshot
of the network or snapshot of what
you're doing at this moment or what
you're consuming at this moment you
think about this person is sort of
managing that they have a long career on
the site and they actually and they
serve and they said goals
correspondingly respondent incentives
correspondingly so for example wikipedia
where you see this very large community
right if we don't think the articles but
about the people producing them we see a
community where people can for example
log up to say 10,000 edits on the system
at which point they come up for
promotion to this system administrator
role and you can actually watch because
wikipedia really sort of relentlessly
chronicles absolutely mean it happens on
the site you can see actually the
deliberations about someone's promotion
to the admin shift role they submit a
couple of a cv it looks sort of like a
tenure case and that's all going on sort
of behind the scenes of wikipedia right
people who really have invested a lot of
time in this simply the kind of goals
people set themselves in educational
sites the kinds of questioning answering
that you see on Stack Overflow er again
people develop expertise I'll talk about
that as well so I want to talk about
sort of how people's long-range
decision-making how we might try to
model some of that in these in these
systems the sort of guiding framework is
really rather than thing about the you
know network of what's going on
explicitly we're gonna think about the
state space that people are Trevor
cursing right so we imagine that there's
some large state space of activities I
could do on the site and my career in
the system is some kind of traversal
through that that that's state space and
in that state space we can say effort
and careers cost but you're heading
toward various rewards now some of the
rewards might be intrinsic just you
doing what you were trying to get done
on the site others might be things that
the site designer puts into the system
and one of those kinds of rewards we see
in a lot of these domains including all
of these our systems of badges they say
if you do this much of this activity
you'll get some kind of a prize a reward
a badge different sites do this in
different ways but you could think of
them as sort of ways of trying to steer
behavior on the site and there are lots
of ways of thinking about how badges
might operate ranging from the social
psychological up to the game theoretic
so I want to talk about how these
rewards work in these systems and again
sort of talking about two lines of work
it begins with us work with Ashley
Anderson dan hunt Locker in the oriole
escovitch where we we sort of started by
trinity and how do badges work in these
systems right how's the people's
behaviors is being steered by them we
looked at two domains in particular on
Stack Overflow where we tried to look at
the effect of some of these badges and
secondly some interventions that we did
on Coursera where we tried to help them
deploy badges in their forums and then
secondly some more theoretical work that
I've been doing with segal or ran look
at how this planning works when you
think about some of the behavioral
biases that we know the people exhibit
and how we can take that into account
okay so just to kind of make sure we all
have sort of a consistent picture let me
talk about just briefly Stack Overflow
where we did some of this analysis so
the idea was stack overflow and many of
you have used it I certainly use it
regularly for implementation questions I
have that come out by I do it as a
consumer and that's in fact i love how
stack overflow is intended right so it's
a question answering site some people
more adventurous than me actually come
and ask questions to the community like
this person is trying to compute
connected components in a graph with 100
million nodes and so they pose the
question and then there are some answers
to the question
and so they're sort of a number this was
not me no I as I said there's something
much braver than me because I I just go
and hope someone already asked it so I
can just kind of lurk in the shadows and
consume the answer but so the things no
so there's a question there are some
answers and there are votes right so
people up vote the answer to say I think
this is a good answer and you might also
notice maybe the sort of least visible
to normal users of the site is you can
also up fo up the questions and that's
important for them because they actually
think of themselves as not just
answering questions the real time but
producing resources for shy people like
me who just want to come and read them
you know up to a year later and not have
to ask the community directly okay so
that's a that's kind of a picture of the
stack overflow page and implicit in this
is actually that the designers of the
site might want more certain kinds of
activities and less of us write more
answers may be fewer questions or at
least more answers per question more
voting more adding of this metadata so
we know which is the good content on the
site we'd like to do all of that and so
we sort of imagine that there's this
interaction going on between the site
designer and the population of users
right the site designer has a certain
ideal mix of activities that they would
like to see they're like see exactly
right mix of answers per question and
voting of other things going on the user
is just want to get done what they want
to get done some people are there to get
their questions answered some people are
there to display their expertise and to
help others and you know these people
have these motivations and so the
question is how does that interaction
work right the designer has the ability
to introduce incentives into the site to
try steering steering behavior and so
when Ashton Dan you're in our thing
about this you know we thought it would
be kind of nice if we could have some
kind of abstract model of people
traversing estate space activities
asking and answering and voting at all
these things right and so people's lives
would sort of you these trajectories of
paths through this state space and we
sort of feel like we would know we're on
the right track with think about these
incentives if we could actually sort of
see the tree actually sort of bending
toward certain incentives and in a way
we first stumbled upon this idea of
modeling this way precisely in this way
we were visual trying to find different
ways of visualizing people's life times
on the thing you know on the system and
we notice you know there's sort of
people following these sort of flow
lines to the system and they were
actually sort of you know
sort of warping in certain parts of the
space or like you know what's going on
here it was also good sort of a
gravitating body that was sort of
warping them and when you look closely
it turned out there was a badge there
that someone had set up you know and
that was actually sort of bending all of
their behavior toward it and so we
thought okay you know can we come up
with a model that as simply as possible
has it has that kind of steering
activity so here was the first model
that we suggested for how bad just might
work I'll sort of spell this out see you
can see what some of the issues are and
then again I'll sort of move on to sort
of some of the richer ways of trying to
model what users are actually doing here
so again we have a state space which
means in our case we just have a set of
actions that you can do so there's
action type 1 action or type 2 and so
forth and maybe people I keep the
running example stack overflow you know
asking and answering voting and so forth
so therefore a user's state is n
dimensional imagine that a user has some
preferred distribution of what they like
to do so actually a bunch of ways of
modeling what the user might be how
these might be operate on the site this
turned out to be sort of a nice one even
though it has a bit less choice a bit
more randomness so essentially you know
when this 2d state says a user is going
to go right with Pete probably p1 and up
with probably p2 right they're going to
do an action type 1 or national type 2
and so users lifetime in the system is
just a little particle moving up into
the right you're having this kind of
move random walk up into the right and
then the user has some finite lifetime
they exit the system is probably Delta
at each step right because maybe they
change jobs and their new job is much
more time demanding out of time for
stack overflow you know whatever it is
but there might just be some reason why
they just have to leave and that of
course creates a natural discounting of
the future right so up into the right
and then aged evaporate with some
problem okay on top of this we're going
to put badges and so a badge is
basically any monotone subset of the
state space as and once you're in the
subset you stay in the subset as you
keep going up into the right so the blue
badge says if you're right of here you
get a badge the red line says if you're
up here you get the red badge man says a
blue badge in a red veg and there's a
reward that gets conferred when you
actually get the badge all right so now
a user has to choose what does their
distribution of reactions going to be
they have a preferred distribution P but
they could choose any description they
want so they could choose some of the
distribution X particularly then maybe
they want to get the bed
more quickly so they choose some other X
now when they choose a different
distribution that comes at some cost G
of X P because which say has caused zero
when you're doing your preferred
distribution and for any other
distribution the more you have to
deviate from what you wanna be doing the
more costs you incur all right so with
this set up the user now faces an
optimization problem how would they like
to behave in the site as a function of
where they are where they are in the
state space all right and their choice
is how to is to pick a distribution so
as to achieve all the different rewards
the badges not incurring costs from
deviant for thing what I do and
effectively the solving the following
optimization problem so they're trying
to choose in each state a right so a
given state here a distribution which
has n dimensions in this case to two
dimensions what are their probabilities
and they optimize the following utility
which actually although I wrote it out
in this long form is pretty simple to
decompose right there are three terms to
it so there's the badges they've won
that confers utility there's the costs
they incur from not doing what they want
to be doing and then there's the
recursively the value in the future
right that's their value right now with
probably one minus Delta they survive to
the next step and they have this dynamic
programming recurrence right was
probably XA to the I they go and
dimension I in which case they now
evaluate their utility here okay and so
again it's sort of designed to serve as
simply as possible to incorporate you
know what I want to be doing the value
from badges and my thinking about the
future as a dynamic program it's not
actually that hard to solve although
there's one twist which is you know we
always teach you know figure out the
base case for your dynamic program and
then build up from there here the
problem is that you know when I'm here
I'm recursively thinking about these two
states and when i'm there think about
those states and it sort of extends out
to infinity so we have to do a be a bit
careful to somehow ground the induction
somewhere out here and the trick
basically is that once I'm past all the
badges the site if there's a finite set
of bed is the site designer has lost all
control over my behavior and so I sort
of know what'll happen out there and I
can start sort of marching backers so
again you know we thought is this going
to actually produce this kind of bending
that we saw when we visualize people's
activities on on the site right that the
this idea as you got near the bed was
like a sort of gravitating body that was
pulling you and if you try out some
solutions to this numerically right so
you actually see that that's that's
exactly what's happening in this model
so in the next slide we just sort of
made up some you know numbers for what
the cost function should be what the
what Delta should be and so forth and
that's what you actually see as the
vector field what people are doing at
every point of the state space right so
they start out here and they have some
preferred direction again a direction
here as a probability probably of one
probably of two we could actually tell
what their preferred direction is
because once they're past the two badges
they we have no control from the bit is
keep going that way and you see at the
very beginning they kind of do what they
want to be doing because why because
this one minus delta term says I'm
likely to leave the system before I ever
get to the badge the badge is so far off
what are my real chances of actually
getting the bad I'll just do what I want
to be doing but as you survive longer
and longer the notion of winning this
badge becomes more and more real to you
and so you know as you start you know
and if you sort of randomly flipped a
few more heads than tails and you're
over here this badge is much more
salient than that [ __ ] because it's not
very it's not so discounted anymore you
really might get it and so you begin
actually at optimality torquing your
behavior so you get to this of course
once you through this badge now what's
sailing to this badge and so forth so
again what's what sort of intriguing to
us is that these kinds of arguments that
you know rewards acquire salience as you
need near them it's definitely a big
topic in cognitive psychology so things
like the gold gradient hypothesis argue
that badges are salient as you as you
approach them because you're trying to
reach closure on some long running tasks
that you completed or that you started
what was interesting to us is that here
it's arising purely just from a dynamic
programming solution right the agent
isn't sort of actually thinking you know
why would I try for the agent is an
actually thinking boy it looks so real
now the agent is simply optimizing
something with exponential discounting
but that's of course going to going to
have the same effect okay and you can
project this onto one dimension this is
sort of what looks like if you're
approaching a badge on a one you know so
as you do more more actions the battery
with a 25 you're going to ramp up of
course as you punch through the badge
boundary
going to drop back to what you were
doing that's actually one case where we
difference or sharply with the
psychological theories like gold
gradient those theories tend to say
there's also a little and effective
learning going on that as you do this
activity more and more action a one you
say you know actually kind of like this
action I've become habituated doing it
once I get the batter me to keep doing
it where is this optimization argument
says you're going to drop back to what
you what you were doing and of course we
expect it will be different in different
domains it's not so much to say one or
the other is right but to notice that
that's actually 24 very urgent
consequence to these theories so we can
go into Stack Overflow you see in second
good question yeah so next slide I'll
show you a picture doesn't that
distinction arise because your P your
preferred distribution is independent of
the state like shouldn't yeah it could
be allowed to evolve and that's actually
an important thing this day in program
is extremely general so if you wanted
this to be P sub a it would be the same
yeah and then you might see that exactly
so it's certainly one could one could
build that in you could say States
beyond this now have that lymington
built in and you actually don't like
doing it now and we could tell you cuz I
didn't it is a good question what
happens on stackoverflow I'll show you
the too bad just sort of most perfectly
at the time we looked at when Stack
Overflow had had many fewer badges and
so is now the two that most perfectly
fit this model of sort of cumulative
milestones without lots of other bells
and whistles we're badges from voting so
one was the civic duty badge which said
if you vote three hundred times you get
a badge and the other was the electrode
patch was said if you've got six hundred
times on questions you also get an even
bigger badge or at least a badge that's
harder to get because that's 600
question votes not just 300 total votes
and so here's what looked like s people
approached those badges and so I try to
draw the pictures sort of in the same
way but this is from the actual Stack
Overflow data so this is actions we've
done the same thing it turned out to the
curse we're bit easier to interpret if
you did number of days relative to badge
way and see here everybody who's ever
won a civic duty badge with you hundred
votes we've aligned all of their life
histories so the x 0 is for everybody
the day they won the badge right and you
see that's ramping up on the two things
that are being reward
by the badge question votes and answer
votes the other two activities that are
unbinding remain flat so locally in the
part of the state space that's into the
scene of the badge you don't see an
effect on these UDC a sharp effect on
these and you do see a pretty rapid
relaxation to some base rate and since
I'm moving quickly to this I'm happy to
talk afterwards about some of the other
issues that we looked at here you also
notice with the electric bad right it's
very clear only this is being rewarded
as a gigantic cliff at the end of this
one it's also and it's sort of hard to
tell exactly but if you're asking as
they do this what are they stealing
activity from right so here they're
doing more of this they're not doing
less of anything else arguably just
doing more stack overflow activity here
similarly although you could argue that
they're doing a little less as a belt
more in questions a little bit less
funny than answers which hints although
it sort of hard to tell from the amount
data we have but it sort of hinted some
interesting conjecture about mental
categorization right if I have to vote
more in questions I have to steal
activity from something which I steal
from it should be the other activity
involves voting but not the red and blue
activities which are actually about
writing takes again a conjecture more
than anything else okay so a bunch of
questions that you could ask here I'll
mention one which actually i think is is
a nice question and we don't have a
great understanding how solvent we can i
call the the badge placement problem all
sort of a facility location problem in
state space where I say I'm allowed to
define some fixed number of badges with
some fixed set of rewards I'd like to do
it in a way that steers activity and
them in some pattern that I desire as
the site designer and so I specify
here's the cumulative distribution of
activities I would like on the site I
have a limited vocabulary badges I can
place them however I want how should i
do that i don't get in an interesting
interesting algorithmic problem which i
think fits natural in this model a
second question that we we asked about
yeah it's interesting though I mean the
secret that does it as a facility
location you have to have a mole of what
will happen after you design the badge
yeah just the same way the P
imagine that they ever get up to the
badge right I guess maybe I'm wrong that
the site designers don't really imagine
how much people will or will not answer
on the site do you think people know
this out of time so this is of course
the entry question is there give me
enough data arising from this I feel
like as these sites deploy more more
badges with really stack overflow is
very hard to tell from these examples
you know so the hope would be and again
it's it's been harder than it looked so
it's very valid question that if you
look at things in the vicinity of badge
wins you're seeing something about how
much more salient is the badge when I'm
this far from it that when I'm that far
from it so I'm getting some kind of
effective slope on people's awareness of
the badge which might help me a little
bit that's it yeah supervision so maybe
I'm misinterpreting the plots it feels
like there's a bit of selection bias
here so there's obviously a lot of
people who maybe got close to the badge
and didn't never wanted yeah I guess I'm
so it just feels different than what you
were talking about on the previous slide
right the previous slide is sort of
saying it finds you approach it it's
gonna yeah more effort so it seems like
what what I would want to see is among
the pool of people who got close to a
badge win right how much is that which
is not am i right that's not possible
reaction character not possible to
ralphing area that song we've looked at
a bit with the reputation score we have
them much much more fine-grained control
over as you approach reputational
milestones one sees some of that but
it's a that's also yeah a very good
question well this is days versus
actions yeah yeah timers actions does
not make a big difference so that so you
don't extend that a TI no you don't you
don't accelerate built-in actions in you
do more actions per day and you also
accelerate ordinary in action means that
this this axis is elongated closely
inocencia yeah
see any evidence that tears like you
were changing their underlying
preference distribution like in the left
plot it looks like the yellow line ends
up higher than it started as that
statistically significant yeah it's a
good question I mean again the question
is what it's relaxing to in the long run
versus where it is here the sense is
that and again it's sort of hard to tell
as you move for the way when you're
right here this is significant but as
you move freely up does not slightly
much evidence that it's permanently
higher questions yeah do you see sample
selection bias do you see people
answering easier questions yeah so we
looked at actually this is when we
looked at so the quality so as you get
close to the badge win do you see for
example dust-up voting of the because we
have some quality measure of your
answers or do you see in the voting did
you see people sort of doing the easy
ones like they vote on things they've
all we have a lot of votes not much
evidence of that but it feels like
there's something there ought to be
ought to be the case but the sort of
obvious checks for like our people just
sort of finding the easy things and
doing the fast possible not yeah but
that's definitely something that we went
went looking for it um and then this is
also this other question just right how
our badges driving their value anyway
right so you know is the reason that I'm
seeing people that other people have
badges and I want to be like them is it
that I'm you know sort of it's providing
me with my own motivation is it
transactional once I have a badge on
certain sites and unlock certain
abilities and therefore the very
concrete payoff from from getting them
these are all also interesting up in
questions one thing we did to just try
helping our own thing about this was
when we worked with Coursera to
introduce badges into the forum we
actually there did try a randomized
experiment with different presentations
of the badges to different random subset
of the population so the idea was on the
forums you're going to get badges for
you know for reading for impose for
providing answers they have lots of
upvotes and a bunch of other things and
so we presented the badges in
different ways so here was here's one
presentation said you can get a bronze
silver gold or diamond edge for either
for reading posts for voting for getting
up voted posts and and for other things
and so you presented this badge ladder
for a random subset of population we
also when you went on the forum you saw
everybody's badges on there by lines he
saw not just the name but you also saw
what badges they had an interesting
thing there was that actually to a
statistically significantly higher
extent there was more form usage for the
people who saw this presentation that
who just saw the names alright so making
the badges salient and the bylines of
other people actually was you know in
the random sample which had that was
producing higher effect actually
similarly we can do this presentation or
can just say you know you have some
badges the idea with this presentation
which we sort of tried to make the
progress more salient again making that
Morsi an idol also produced a higher
effect so you know one question is you
know how to tease apart why these
effects are happening it's just through
increasing awareness of them is it
through activating social hughes also i
think an interesting question but i
think there is a sort of interesting
challenge i understand to help the edges
are deriving their value um so let me
talk a bit about modeling of people's
the sort of long range planning behavior
because what I've been talked about so
far is this very simple model of the
future where I'm optimizing and I'm
discounting the future you know to some
extent geometrically but we've also
think about you know cases where
something more complicated seems to be
happening right so we can talk about so
far is we have these multi-step plans an
agent is choosing the optimal sequence
given the costs and benefits one
question is you know why is this not a
perfect model for what's going on one of
course is that the costs and benefits
may just not be known to the user they
may be changing over time you know so
for example the Tacoma public school
system which created this interesting
treasure map for how to earn a high
school diploma you know sort of
described all the kind of you know
quicksand and the treasure chest and all
the things along the way you know it
could be that one reason why you don't
finish your high school diploma is
simply because while you're in the mill
high school
your parents both lose their jobs you
need to start earning income for your
family all sort of unexpected things
happen but sometimes it seems like you
change your mind even though the costs
and benefits seem to have remain the
same the whole time right and that
wouldn't be explainable by some kind of
fixed optimization problem if if in the
beginning you thought it was optimal to
embark on this plan and the cost
structure and the ROI structure didn't
change why are you now the ending and
halfway through are you doing something
differently halfway through right and
that's what what a behavioral scientist
referred to as time inconsistency
probably high school graduation is less
the obvious place to see it the probably
most obvious place to see it is
something like gym membership right the
start of the month you think this is
gonna be great I'm going to join the gym
I meet lots of exercise it's going to be
just a great investment of my 19 pounds
95 and and so but then you know once you
join the gym you know the month starts
on the first few days you realize you
don't actually like they do you know the
idea of getting up at six thirty in the
morning to go do this just doesn't seem
so appealing and so you don't do it and
time goes on and the gym has pocketed
another person's monthly membership um
again you know it's not that three days
in you sprained your ankle and couldn't
do it it's you know you knew in advance
you would be having to get up at 630am
it just didn't seem this appealing when
the time came to actually do it now
that's not a behavior I'm going to be
able to get out of some kind of
geometric discounting where I say here's
you know the reward is being physically
fit the cost is going up at 630am the
time is discounted you would have made
of a plan and you would have followed
that plan that is not what happened here
you made a play on you didn't stick to
it um there are a lot of sort of example
is sort of this one which people have
attempted or have proposed a number of
models for in the behavioral economics
literature one of the simplest stories
actually comes from this varnish short
paper by the Nobel laureate George
Akerlof where he begins with a story and
the story is why did george akerlof not
make it to the post office so the idea
was so he was on sabbatical in india and
as the sabbatical units and he had this
giant cardboard box of things he had to
send back to the US and actually it was
for a friend of
needed it and there was a sort of a lot
of extra details to the story the basic
issue was that he had to ship it in one
of the final end days of his sabbatical
in India it was going to be a costly
proposition to ship it because what he
have to you have to go the post I she
have to wait in this very long line if
to fill out lots of forms lots of
customs information you know you're
going to lose a half day doing this it's
a real pain so there's this one time
effort cost of sea to ship it other hand
do not you know it's going to have to
get there eventually and every day it's
not being shipped there's a loss of use
cost because it's not at the other end
so you're paying some small amount x
every single day don't ship it ok so he
had to side one to ship it and just to
spell this out he faced this intriguing
optimization problem that if he ships it
on day t his cost is the one time cause
c + TX and just a kind of shortcut to
the end the optimum for that is actually
t equals one you should ship it on on
the first day ok so that's why should
have done but that's not what he did
what he did is what may be a number of
us can relate to he procrastinated so
each day he didn't do it that day
because there other things that just
seemed kind of you know worth doing that
day he planned he would do it tomorrow
actually he makes the point this in the
paper which is going to be important for
later it's not the plane to do it
sometime he planned he would do it
tomorrow and the effect of course is you
wait until day n when it at that point
you have to ship it and so you do you
incur the cost of see anyway you all
kind of know this right so we've all
experienced this um actually the story
has a few more twists and turns halfway
into this some friends of his took pity
on him and just they took it to the post
office so didn't quite answer ok so he
did something that all of us you know
have done in similar situations but he
also decided that maybe all of us
haven't done which is he tried to model
his own behavior here so here with the
idea he was actually drawing them work
from behavioral sciences from several
decades earlier the idea being that
costs incurred today are more salient
let's imagine that we simply had one
tiny feature to the story that anything
I'm going to incur today is raised by
this factor of be greater than one so
any costume occur today it looks
different from all the future costs no
this is not discounting right
discounting says the future looks like a
1 minus delta shrunken copy of the
present and that's what's going to
continue recursively all the way you
know so i just see this kind of
vanishing exponentially decaying view of
the future that's not this this says
today is different from
every other day you could add just
counting on top of this if you wanted
but discounting treats every day as a
fixed diecut okay what effect does that
have it actually does exactly what the
procrastinating agent in the story would
do if you stand today your cost is B
times C right these bigger than one C is
big you sent tomorrow you get B times X
X is right so X is a small number so
it's entirely possible that B times C is
bigger than BX plus C that happens as
long as you get this inequality and so
that actually the optimum would be not
to San today incurring bc but the Senate
tomorrow incurring BX plus C certainly
not the day after tomorrow because you
just add pointlessly got an extra extra
tomorrow tomorrow is the best dresser
okay so that's the idea now this grew
into a very large area and behavioral
economics on time and consistency and
present bias right the bias toward calls
in the present the sort of core
reference for the small I'm talking
about here is this notion of quasi
hyperbolic discounting due to David
leibson we're essentially a cost reward
see realize two units in the future has
a present value that some fixed
multiplier beta times the discounting
factor x see our special case here is
just that Delta's one we're not
discounting be is just the same as the
inverse of data and also one crucial
point which will be true throughout the
rest of what I'm gonna say and the final
private stock the agent is naive about
about their bias as in they believe that
tomorrow they won't experience the bias
that's an interesting point which I'll
mention them on the final slide we're
doing trying to say about okay the nice
thing with this model is you can model a
bunch of ways in which people reason
badly about time one is procrastinations
we just saw a second one in this nice
paper of a Donahue Raven is task
abandonment you start a project right so
you start this eighth chapter monograph
which is gonna be great and you write
the first three chapters in a burst of
enthusiasm and then without much in
particular changing in the world use
somehow never quite finish and it sits
there on your hard drive and all that
effort went to waste and similarly the
benefits of choice reduction if you
remove options from people you give them
less choice you can actually make their
lives better what you get an agent who
could plan perfectly that would make no
sense because optimizing ovary
your feasible region should only be
better than optimizing or smaller
feasible region but when he tries the
people you often find this is happening
so what was interesting to us was there
was a sort of rich literature but each
of these stories with its own kind of
intricate construction right so each of
them you know the models all once you
got into the specifics were all slightly
different you have to sort of construct
these things carefully and we thought to
ourselves you know is there way to sort
of think comparatively across all of
these different scenarios right with
everyone framework where we sort of ask
all these questions procrastination and
task abandonment and choice reduction
all sort of concurrently right or could
we ask you know as we're fond of doing
in theory of computer science
comparative questions about performance
like things about like the cost ratio
right so you know if I imagine things
like the competitive ratio or the price
of Anarchy here to be a kind of a price
of your rationality price of present
bias you know what be the worst possible
cost incurred by a present pious agent
over the minimum cost the optimum plan
okay you know and so you can sort of
imagine across the high school
graduation story in the gym membership
in the post office across all stories
but it hasn't effect what's the worst
cost ratio and the obvious problem is I
haven't yet formalized things enough to
even be able to ask the question I mean
what am I exactly asking am I asking the
max overall stories of the cost ratio
and really know how to do that I need
some way of saying let's comparatively
talk about any possible domain where
this is happening you know again within
some constraint set I'll make up what
the scope of the model is but at least
it should be sort of rich enough to
cover the kinds of stories we're talking
about so the idea was to go back tues
today to state spaces right people
moving through a state space traversing
a state space trying to get to a goal
and you know let's take away the grid
structure and just say suppose I had an
arbitrary directed acyclic graph an
agent starts at s there are costs on the
edges indicating you know this is the
cost to perform this action and they're
trying to get to state t all right and
this is a shortest path problem if the
agent we're looking here they'd say this
has it cost of twenty that's the
cheapest path I'll do that the one twist
I'm going to make is that we're going to
introduce present pies from a given
though the immediately outgoing edges
have cost raised by a factor of B so my
example let me say B is to just because
that's you know that's a simple thing
pedagogically to talk about so if B were
to hear this
would look like it has cost thirty two
plus two plus two is 36 this would look
like ice costs 32 and this would have
cost 34 you can try out the math so the
agent looking here says you know I just
don't feel like doing this gigantic and
cost a 16 something to go this way right
it's suboptimal in the real cost of
incurring because black is the real
costs are incurring right you actually
didn't have the box back in the US
because you didn't go to the post office
and you actually did lose the twenty
dollars because you know and so forth
right so the Blackhawks are the actual
costs are incurring this is what's
warping your path okay now of course
once they get here the world looks
different this now looks like it's 8
times 2 plus 8 24 this looks like it's
only 20 so in fact they go this way so
two things happen in this example one
they were suboptimal and two they don't
even do what they planned when they're
standing here they change their mind
when they got to hear all because things
were salient at different points in time
okay what's interesting is that you can
serve effortlessly with this graph
structure model a bunch of the stories
I've been talking about right this is an
arbitrary graph just for a pedagogical
example this is the George Akerlof story
right here he is on day 0 trying to say
i went to go to the post office every
day node VI means you reached a 3
without going to the post office on any
day you can go straight to the post
office incurring a cost of c or you can
kind of orbit you can kind of idle and
pay X and just be back where you started
right and so his story was one of how he
didn't just take the direct route to t
he kind of went all the way around the
perimeter and then went to t incurring
the sort of pointless extra cost on the
outside ok so again very easy to build
these kinds of examples it's actually
sufficiently easy that let me just add
one more thing to the model which is I
could say you don't need to get to T
right because I'd like to model other
things like task abandonment in which
you have the option to stop it right
three chapters into your eighth chapter
monograph you could decide you know
actually I just don't feel like doing
this so you could say all right there's
a reward at node T mom and the age is
only going to continue on their path if
the cost they perceive to the end is
less wrinkle to the reward that they see
at the end so again with be equals to
what would happen here the agent would
say this path looks like 10 that looks
like 11 we're multiplying these up by
two they can go this way but they get
here and this looks like 12 and so in
fact they
you give up they stopped because 12 is
bigger than 11 and so they put in this
effort and that effort went to waste so
that's task abandoned and of course
choice reduction is very easy to notice
in this model if someone were to sort of
helpfully just delete that node this
would look like 11 it's worth the reward
of 11 maybe i love them i epsilon if you
want and then they go this way and they
actually stick to it because they get
here in it looks like tim and so if i
take away your freedom you actually do
better we show you one more example
because it's very easy to construct
these things an elaborate story that you
can find in lurcher on the value of
assigning deadlines and classes again
it's just a story about a path and
graphs so the story about deadlines and
classes is to say we all know from you
know if we've been instructors and
courses you know you have problem sets
and if you taught the course a number of
years you sort of roughly know what
kinds of questions you want to ask and
yet you have every week a problem said
and it's due the next week and you could
say well I know the questions are in
advance you're all grown-ups here are
all eight problem sets pace yourselves
hand them all in on your own schedule by
the end of the semester and then they'll
they'll be good because you just have
more freedom and you can budget your
time and anyone who's tried doing this
knows this is a complete disaster
because people don't actually start the
problem sets and now you start getting a
lot of drum in the final two weeks when
there's eight problems that's left to go
and there's two weeks left in the class
and the question of you know why didn't
you budget your time better is sort of
at this point kind of moved because
there's only two weeks left to go again
present bias sort of makes this sort of
very very easy to see so you know you
can imagine there's a just to take a
simple example say I had a three-week
short course I had two projects I get a
reward of 16 at the end and each week
that I am in the chorus it cost me one
to just be in the course not do any
other two projects it cost me four to do
one of them it cost me nine to do both
of them in the same week because cost to
do things like that are often convex
like that so I just say write node v IJ
v 2 1 here is two weeks have gone by and
I've only done one project so I won't
walk through all of the math here but
you can work out that what someone will
do just a graph traversing agent would
say all right they're going to go here
that looks cheapest they really should
start starting the work but they don't
they go here because they say I'm going
to do it all in a big burst at the end
because that was like the cheapest path
to them right now because it's 2 times 1
plus the nine they get here of course
now they have to do to front one week
that's 2 times 9 is 18 not worth over 16
and they drop the class and you could
have made their lives easy by just
deleting that state if you delete that
state everything gets better they
actually make it to the end and what is
deleting that state it's just putting in
a deadline it's saying you must have
done the first Prague project by the
second week of the class if you do that
they'll actually finish a class that
they would not have finished otherwise
with the present once again the point is
actually less to sort of focus on
classes and problem sets and deadlines
but just to say that like really
effortlessly tell many many of the
stories in the literature just by
constructing the right graph and looking
what a path following agent would do now
with graphs you can do a bunch of things
so we've been sort of talking about that
this one I'll just sketch a couple of
things that we've we've done sort of in
the final five minutes um why don't you
actually try characterizing instances
with high cost ratios second one is you
can think about this idea of choice
reduction is sort of a graph algorithmic
problem how could I optimally reduce
your choice in order to help present
bias agents complete Chester they did in
those examples and the third is you
could ask sort of how do populations
different when they have different
values of B I'll mainly just talk about
this first one here so in fact the cost
ratio can be quite bad the accra law
story is nowhere near as bad as it could
have been right life could have been
worse it could have been but the cost to
do this thing is actually getting
exponentially worse as time goes on but
unfortunately for the agent as long as
the c is less than B the multiplier at
every step you'd still want to defer
just one more this is a story that we
can recognize those almost sort of too
painful to contemplate right but it's
sort of going on it's just getting worse
and worse but you still somehow prefer
just waiting one more week so so you
were here as a question we asked which
again we couldn't have asked if we were
just talking about stories but we can
ask we're talking about graphs over all
instances with a high cost ratio right
so this is a version of a curl off story
is that the case that any instance with
a lard you know with a hike especially
high cost ratio must somehow contain a
curl off story as a sub structure and
because we're talking my graphs that
question actually is can be made well
defined must anything with a very large
cost ratio have this as a sub structure
here's how we could do that we could use
the national craft miners as a
definition of sub structure so just to
kind of in two slides remind you
graff minor I just mean that I know a
graph H small graph age is a minor of a
big graph G if I can take connected
subsets of G like this contract them
into super nodes like this and get a
copy of age so the point here is that
this has AK 4 minor the complete graph
on four nodes because those are my four
sets they're mutually adjacent ok what
might my question be here using the idea
of graph miners so i'll actually scrub
out the costs in the directions and say
let's suppose this and again there are a
bunch of ways we could formalize this
question i think a number of them are
actually correct i'll just tell you
about this particular simple one if we
take away costs and directions we could
say this is sort of the signature of the
akerlof story right this fan graph where
there's a path with spokes going into a
central node will call that the k fan
and so here's a the theorem that sigil
and i were able to prove about this
model that effectively whenever there's
an exponential cost ratio you must have
a large fan as a graph minor in the
instance so for every lambda greater
than one there's an epsilon so that if
the cost ratio exceeds land at the end
then the underlying instance actually
has to have a kfan minor where k is
epsilon times it it's actually a
constant fraction of the whole instance
is a picture of the actor love story
somewhere embedded in there our bounds
were quite loose actually in fall apart
by tongue at all there was a so much
work to actually found the sort of tight
trade-off in this in this graph my
everything and the basic idea here which
I just have only time to go into for one
slide is that essentially as with all
these graft minor construction kinds of
arguments you know this one was nowhere
near as difficult as as many of them you
basically need to build the minor piece
by piece by sort of following what's
going on the graph right so particularly
the agent is traversing a path trying to
reach T its path to the target is
getting more and more expensive and so
we can say the rank of the node is
basically the sort of integer of the
logarithm of its current distance to T
so it has to acquire a gigantic rank as
it goes right a gigantic log of cost and
what we argue is that every time the
rank goes up by one we actually can
identify yet another path that it could
have taken to get to t that's separate
from the path that's following and so I
basically pull all these together into a
super node look at this and that's
actually my k family the actual proof is
a bit longer than that but that's that's
the basic idea
okay let me tell you one more question
we asked and then I'll wrap up one of
the question we asked which i think is
still some nice open questions here is
the choice reduction problem so suppose
I have a graph G it's not reversible by
the agent I'd like to find a sub graph
of it the dystrophy ball right that was
my story here right the agent we get
stuck at the node up top because it no
longer wants to get there if i delete
that and now gets to the target I'd like
to know when can I do that forgiving
graph I can take a graph I can try the
agent right there deterministic I to see
what they do and I can tell they get
stuck the harder question is is there a
subset of the nodes I can delete so that
they make it all the way through can I
produce a traversable instance now when
we first saw this question we thought
okay this won't be that hard because you
know surely if there's a traversable sub
graph that means in that reversible sub
graph there's a path they follow and if
we could just delete maybe everything
but that path then maybe they'll just
follow it or if not that path maybe some
path sort of felt like if they're a
traversable sub graph there ought to be
one that's just a path I mean that's
sort of true in almost any sort of model
of path finding that you tend to think
about but that's not the case in this
model so we discovered this graph which
is quite intriguing this graph has the
property that's traversable but no path
in a dystrophy ball right so what do I
mean by that when you're here you say
I'm going to I'm plan to reach the
target because this is 2 times 2 plus 6
plus two is 12 which is at most a reward
12 so I move on to a I get to a and now
this looks like two times six plus two
is 14 that's too difficult but suddenly
this path comes to the rescue this looks
like 2 times 3 plus 6 which is 12 and so
I continued on I make it to the target
right so without no be here I would
never get to a now without nodes see
here i would never continue onward from
it right we sort of thought about is
this really affect about graphs or is
this to somehow a story that was sort of
latent in the world I guess in the end
we convince ourselves it is sort of
story that's latent in the world by mean
this is essentially the convincing your
six-year-old child to take violin
lessons by showing them youtube videos
of violent prodigies performing in
concerts and they think to themselves oh
wow if I take up the violin I'm going to
become a violin prodigy and performing
concerts imagining this path and then
you get here and you realize you know
actually
it's going to take like a lot of
practice every day that's really hard
but by then they actually are they enjoy
the violin and they're doing this and
they end up having you know reaching
this reward which is ultimately
fulfilling to them even though it's not
the path they actually in the same way
that's a benign version the story it
also I mean it's the case that when you
think about these design problems you're
also you know sort of you know you serve
at this interface with things that are
sort of deceptive practices right you
can induce someone to put a huge amount
money into something by constantly sort
of exploiting their present bias to make
them think that they're reaching or it
into something wrong about that so you
know this is this is sort of a values
neutral structure that says you know
this can be used you know to help people
accomplish what they want to accomplish
you can also sort of lead people on to
into bi directions so another written
questions here it turned out that this
was the tip of the iceberg there was
sort of two independent proofs one by if
i get 1 by the aforementioned paper of
tongue at all it's actually just this
basic problem can i delete nodes to make
this craft reversible is an np-hard
problem NP complete and it suggests a
number of interesting open questions
maybe the easiest ones estate is suppose
I give you an instance is not reversible
it's NP hard to decide if i can delete
no sleep addressable suppose there were
a way with reward our star to delete the
nose make it reversible and i allow you
to say increase the reward to to our
star can you then impala real-time find
a way to delete notes right so can i do
some kind of an approximation where i
inflate the reward slightly and now
becomes much more tractable to figure
out do that not something that we
understand very well at the moment okay
and that brings me to the end you know
as with all these things this kind of a
sort of you know movement from looking
at cases in the world where we see
rewards see people following them trying
to think about models of what might
might be going on starting with models
where this sort of a simple discounting
of the future and we can look at dynamic
programming solutions and then sort of
trying to sort of in richer ways exploit
exploit behavioral biases and even
though you know the way in which we you
know added the behavioral bias in this
case was you know very simple to state
it's just taking a traditional surest
path problem and adding one extra
feature it produces these incredibly
rich behaviors and not just rich
subjectively does but the fact that you
know
these simple seeming tasks become an MP
completeness model suggests some of the
complexity gets introduced when you just
introduced this one little bias so I
think there's a lot of extinct ? xual
value reside in their inner or is it
social is a motivational transactional
how does it work when you're designing
for people is a mix of different
motivations a mix of different biases
potentially sophisticated agents I
promised I would have one bullet about
this so this is very nice working folk
Donahue and Raven are agents who are
aware of their own time' consistency
they still want to procrastinate but
they're aware that that's going that
that is also gonna be happening in the
future and so they can then in this way
avoid the worst of it and in some
ongoing work that's ago I doing with
Manish Raghavan it turns out they're
nice ways to incorporate sophistication
into this graph graph theoretic model in
you get a whole set of interesting
further results there multiplayer
settings obviously this is sort of one
agent making decisions by graph we can
imagine agents into interacting with
various levels of bias and
sophistication and finally you know
obviously it's me interesting to sort of
go back into some of these questions
about badges in these online systems you
know and think about you know how do
these ideas around bias and how these
other ideas around long range planning
help us better understand you know
what's taking place in these systems
right as they become richer as we become
more deeply embedded in our in our
everyday lives i think the algorithmic
questions of how we design for them how
we take into account reasonable models
of agent behavior and what that implies
computationally i think those are all
going to be very instant questions going
forward thanks very much
so just a really read us a last point
that you may jump so sophisticated
agents once we have it fitted a journal
we can design commitment like devices
have you got anything to say about
whether you can begin to look at that in
your new framework which this gated
agent yeah so you actually can can can
say so many things about commitment
devices now so for example if you offer
people so some examples we offer people
the ability to inject costs at the
outset to help prevent bad behavior in
the future you actually sometimes in
Kurr wins that way obviously you know
with commitment commun dices you know
you know in a way one sort of
foreshadowing of it is here is sort of
the designer in in these stories like
with choice reduction the designer is
sort of forcibly imposing a terminal
device on a person who is unable to sort
of think of it for themselves but the
agent who sophisticated you could have
them be creating specific right so you
could ask them to engage in choice
reduction at the beginning suppose i
could pay to engage in choice reduction
right so i have to like pay for the
software that's going to block web
browsing certain sites after 10pm but
having done that then i'm more
productive after 10pm i could pay to you
know put my money into something that
you know limits my freedom but and and
so forth so we actually look at these
these trade-offs and commitment vices i
think yeah it becomes it it looks like
it's becomes possible to do I want to
have someone Joseph occasion
so with respect to procrastination I was
wondering if say from the literature or
from your own experiments on the
Coursera if you have seen whether this
product how much of this procrastination
is for doing nothing in its place are
doing another task in its place and if
component of the latter then at this
framework we used to jointly model
multiple tasks and mighty pretty babes
yeah interesting question right so so
it's a question is can it are we seeing
people do nothing versus doing that do
our tasks you know so in some sense we
know anything about what is the space of
possible activities you know even
nothing is some choice exactly what
nothing would be in here it is the case
that this idea of trading off of my
activities is going to be interesting to
put in the model there's nothing a pre
re impossible doing that you know you
can imagine some multi dimensional graph
where if I move in this dimension and
that's effective what the state space
model was doing if I move in this
dimension making progress on this side
if I move in this dimension on some
other side you know the challenge with
looking at any one site is you can look
at how the train off activities within
the site you look a total time on site
you can't know what they're doing
necessarily off the site unless you're
looking at some larger enclosing context
so I think those are all all going to be
interesting but at some level putting
that into the model you know it sort of
adds an extra dimension the graph
becomes richer but that kind of trading
off is certainly something and you know
and you could imagine something much
richer than this where maybe I have
different levels of present bias for
different activities and then you know
how those trade off is another instant
much yo Simon well nutritional look at
the case of the opposite bias the
admission Krista nation yeah we looked a
little bit yeah so we actually actually
in this work that we're doing now we
looked at bounds you can get on future
biased agents would say I sort of I want
a front load activity now of course that
too can lead to suboptimal behavior but
it turns out you for example can't get
exponentially about instances in that
case so you can't you can do so
obstinately but it can't somehow cascade
and so one can prove
better reprimands I mean at the level of
worst case on a given instance future
bias can be worse than present bias on
the instance for instance basis but the
worst case of one is not as bad as the
worst case in the other batches topic it
seems like there's some simple time
metrik things you could do to shed light
on where the value of badges is coming
from so to the extent that the badges
are valuable because they because users
in a community value other others in the
community knowing that they're good
contributors you'll see a discontinuity
Jennifer Don a particular task before
and after the award of the beds you'll
you'll see a discontinuity effect right
right out of whatever the batch
threshold is to the extent that people
value Jasmine's because this good guys
they want to be pro-social in this
community in the band is signaling to
them what kind of behavior this
community values so I should do a not
because a is bad and you nod you could
just look at a new badge comes online
that should scare behavior far away from
the badge threshold yeah simple know
every micro econometrics things you can
do to get it get it East and unpack the
BB a little bit ya know I think it's
going to as we start looking these
systems that have Richard sets of badges
or badges are being introduced over over
over time it gives a lot of
opportunities for doing that I mean
there are these interesting case we're
just continues can happen for multiple
reasons so for example if I want people
to impress that have a badge then once i
have it i stop putting effort into that
on their hand if i had set that as a
kind of mental goalpost like you know
you know it sort of it's going to be
meaningful to me if i can do a hundred
of these edits then once i also might
see a discontinuity and so certain of
them you know discontinuities won't
resolve among those particular things
but there are definitely you know I
think sort of systems that have richer
sets of badges and just sort more people
achieving each of them is going to be a
big opportunity for those so yeah it'd
be great to talk more about about some
of those
coming back to the Badgers I find it
hard to believe that individuals are
actually calculating time discounting
and I wonder if this sinker
approximation going on like I'm
discounting over 360 yeah it's a good
question then again you know the
different question bout sort of how far
in advance am I ramping up wrapping up
my activity yeah it certainly I mean I
don't think there's any as with any of
these models where one's modeling some
kind of optimal decision plan I don't
you there's any claim that one's sort of
doing the exact calculation and trying
to the Optima but yeah the question of
you know am I only discounting say so if
it's far enough out but I guess the
question be if it I have to model
somehow that a badge that's far in the
future still has some meaning to me so
it's not that zero maybe I sort of so
the discounting would have to be like
maybe only three steps out it starts
gaining and value we'd have to think how
to handle that but because I mean it
does seem like you would want something
that says there's no overall effect that
awareness of that is doing something but
sort of over what timescale you know the
sort of change in ceilings of taking
place is a good question
thank you